da komme ich die blitze raus geht das
relativ schnell kaputt der leichten
unterhaltung wir machen weiter mit einer
folge galaxy mit dem kauf der mann
hallo und was möchtest du dieser folge
machen dass er wieder fleißig kommentare
gelesen genau ich werde jetzt probieren
bzw
so ist immer noch dabei
super vorbereitet wer bei derzeit
technisch alle ein bisschen bisherigen
gut ich muss die gussformen nicht aus
holz machen sondern aus aluminium
dres das ist gut zu wissen mit die leute
geschrieben
ich gucke gerade immer noch weiter nach
fossilien oder ferien gold also doch
goldammer wiesthal leute ist es so viel
hin und her immer noch bei deiner
komischem century dominierend waren ja
weg weil ich mich ausgelaugt ob wir
kriege ich das denn weg dass die wächst
also wie wie kann ich mich dann
ausloggen ohne dass sie danach weg sind
dann weißt du dass keiner an das wird
immer so sein glaube ich das richtig
blöd so ansammeln minions committee will
jetzt soll jeder neue million dollar ist
eine lagebeschreibung menschen
wann die folge übrigens hier willkommen
in meinem element 8 nein ich hab hunger
ich hab ja ich habe mich für euch vor
ich muss nicht nein ich hab sie zeigt
was kann ich denn essen das kann ich
erst sagen ich lebe sterben jährlich an
hunger nein nicht glauben ich also dass
mir noch nicht passiert ich bin nicht
direkt und dann die rewe getötet oder so
ich weiß jetzt mal die ganze karte
heraus sehe ich ähnlich brauche also
irgendwas habe ich hier wieder falsch
gemacht und mich jetzt wieder raus
ließen jobs leute ich hatte
warum hat es nicht diesen dies sei
abgeschlossen und schreibt mir wie man
die minions dass die nicht immer weg
gehen dass ich mich ja so auf
hier sind drei spielen unter mir aber
ich fliege über den und die können wir
nichts an aha alter wie auch die weißen
0 da gehabt
ich weiß nicht ich aber nur kurz da war
ich denn die weiße 0
das mysterium ich habe schon gedacht
einfach mal richtig ausgesandt mit table
zu machen
ja wir haben nämlich nur ein in der
stadt bei cap und da bietet sich auch
hinein schartmann table weil was ist das
denn
lx panther anders
wird sie auf jeden fall richtig feiern
sie an hält sie wirklich viel cooler an
solche zehn jahren nicht wenn ich später
noch mal richtig wichtig die einzige
auslöser aber wieder so richtig glauben
so unwichtig und keiner braucht die oder
so dabei wird es hier noch mal ein
bisschen papa für die dinos bestimmt
später also ich auch noch ganz ganz
viele dna sachen herumliegen
im zdf das wichtigste aber mal wieder
finde ich gerade nicht
und zwar in staaten afrikas genau das
den hilfe sagten jetzt einen chart men
table da muss ich ihnen die bücher
drucken damit der erlös ja ich glaube
schon oder oder sonst kann man doch
nicht diese hohen verzauberung kriegen
oder weißt du das selber nicht so viele
verzauberung technisch du bist du bei
dir bin ich da was falsch angela muss
ich mich bei war ein lesen wie sonst was
den staaten angeht war ich einfach da so
derbe nicht im bilde bin ich packe jetzt
einfach mal hier hin da habe ich also
den german travel und zusätzlicher
scannt sexy jetzt wie geht ihr mit der
entscheidung jetzt bist du ich weiß
nicht wer geht super eine harte
entscheidung auf jeden fall das ist
bestand zu mir manchmal hat es merkt ja
ich wollte mal ich musste mir echt ich
will ich will ja nur fossilien
apropos ich will ja nur fossilien
langsam und in die von 56 dafür dass ich
dann mein entschluss machen kann und das
besser ist weiß ich nicht
ich wüsste ich auch gerne so jetzt hab
ich kein eisen mehr
mir wurde nämlich gesagt muss das
normale eisen im normalen ofen
einschmelzen
es hört sich super merkwürdig an ist es
auch die zurich hier seit einer halben
stunde 1 nachweisen und sind eins in
meinem super verwirrt firma hay
ich hoffe es zu essen aber ich hab
nichts beweisen muss man diese diese
strom menschen nach wie vor ich habe es
ja schon mal gesagt sucht die strom
menschen welche stroh menschen sind
etwas so wieso sie schon beim ersten mal
so behindert erklärt dass die zweite
oder dritte folge es ist kann jeder
daran erinnern wie wir einfach so
strohballen die sehen halt aus wie so
eine person nie die fdp dann stehen um
die krähen wegzuhalten das wort fehlt
mir ja ich weiß schon diese ja hexen
scheuchen könnte man die kommentare
sprechen scheuchen hacks entsprechen
genau wie die hexen wegbleiben von fable
nicht alles essen
folglich will auch domínguez in china
klar jeder text sollte ihren garten
stehen ich bin keine hexe kommen
ich bin dumm war ich muss aber auch
einfach nicht mehr
minecraft zerstört unser gehirn hexen
hexen ja was ist dann mit diesen leuten
genau diesen halt so aus also das ist
sind halt nur so häupl okay das ist
kommt das wieder aus hettenhain kannst
du dann abbauen also die heuballen
abbauen die zustrom machen aus dem stroh
ganz viel brot weil das stroh kannst du
nämlich einfach ein crafting table legen
oder einfach in eine box und dann kommt
ja so ein komischer kuddelmuddel raus
wenn ihr den kunden model bretz dann
heißt das auch wirklich kuddelmuddel
kuddelmuddel kuddelmuddel genauso jeder
der vierten folge habe ich das und ich
hab immer noch essen wohl ich okay 64er
stack abgegeben absoluten oder hat
unglaublich viele brote da rauskriegt
okay das finde ich habe noch nie so ein
ich habe noch nie so ein strom menschen
gesehen nie gesehen die so selten oder
oder die villa wahrscheinlich dann am
laufenden band ich bin einmal glaube ich
ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr rom
geflogen und dann habe ich ein paar
kisten ja ich finde aber gerade auch
richtig viele fossilien wieder das freut
mich immer wenn ich mir so eine richtig
kleine kleine große dino armee machen
müsste da noch schreiben ihnen bekennt
sich auch keiner meinen kommentaren mit
dieser ich frag so ganz häufig in den
kommentaren sogar wie mache ich das und
ich kriegte zwei antworten von 300
kommentaren oder so weil keiner kennt
dieser mod ihr gebiet diese fossil als
ich im lotto jackpot ist auf rechts
jetzt habe ich starke moment stahl ok
kommentar teils der figuren immer kurz
ein bisschen fertige feuer hat das hier
feiert dt
ok genau der den kenn ich bin eine gute
beschreibung was ich euch auch frauen
wollte was sie beschreiben können wie
zähne ich mit den ein dino
ich weiß das denn der inner in den
bereich von sechs blöcken wenn er
aufwacht dann ist er eben dino war ich
will ja nicht mal sechs pkw bestehende
in diesem kleinen vier grad wie überall
meine kisten man also das ist echt
ärgerlich beim das ist das ist das
krasseste klassen und minecraft und ein
neuer platz mit dem projekt sei sache
hier wurde auch gesagt das ist total
wichtig sind irgendwie aber ich weiß
noch nicht was ich mit denen machen soll
du kannst damit glaube ich nachher
handel mit diesem team cups sachen
irgendwas benutzen es kann sein dass
lack war oder so weil du kannst anja
prinzip wie bei so einer verzauberung
früher
dieser mod wurde dann auswählen konnten
verzaubern will mit diesem team kasachen
mache je nachdem mit verschiedenen
ärzten und irgendwie sachen dann
einzelne effekte auf deine waffen bauen
von devil vereins davon nicht ob es
ballack oder so hey cool meine leute
haben richtig viel ausgegangen das
funktioniert jetzt auch endlich mit der
kiste das hat nicht geklappt hast du
gesagt hast richtig wo bist du ich bin
richtig intelligent ich habe so viele
forciert ich hab mein stück wenn da
jetzt keine die not heraus kommen dabei
nicht an flips richtiger sondern weil
ich aber richtig doll
dann sollen noch eine kisten sind steht
dabei neun minuten wir wollen die ganze
folge ja nicht so lange diesmal machen
nähe weil wir mehr krieg wieder auf
genauer genau auf den arsch drauf so und
jetzt muss ich mal hier ich habe 15
religion das kann ich mir vielleicht
mein helm eigentlich machen weil ich
alles rein muss ja auch immer noch nach
anstiegen diesen miesen menschen ja ja
es wird alles bald sortiert freunde ball
genau auf zuwachs bei mir so der aber
unten gerade nicht mehr bei mir ist
einfach gerade die bei mir ist einfach
ganz und gewitter am laufen ich habe
übrigens jetzt wieder an die noaa also
ich hab eine dino dna gerade die ist
gerade diese kalte wetter insel in die
kalte wetter selbstverständlich läuft
vielleicht mal neue kür des waffen dinge
die mich jetzt ist
komplett gesprengt wurden es sieht schön
aus mit dem regen ich hätte echt box
dann richtig trüben shader wo das ganze
nicht so farbenfroh sondern das ganze so
ein bisschen ein bisschen traurig ja ich
weiß nicht wie lukas remo am
sternenhimmel soll mein sport ist auch
gleichzeitig die folge hielt noch vier
minuten
dann hörte ich mein schwert auch fertig
sein das wäre echt super cool weil das
gras wird aber ich habe brachiosaurus
dna nach unten auf 4 am start das
braucht er das endlich zahlt man muss
immer aufpassen weil wenn da irgendwas
aus holz hast dann fliegst du dir
komplett alles ermittler wie was ja weil
du ja dann immer blitze macht wenn du
ich weiß nicht was diese schwert kann
ich mache mir einfach bis man blitze und
das macht sehr viel kaputt sind meist
aufpassen dass ich nicht so toll
also habe ich aber aber auch irgendwie
nicht aber irgendwie nicht bei euch bin
grad meditiert weiß meine ganzen sachen
wieder ein so team muss es zu nervig ist
alles offen diesem fall dieser regen das
bringt das ganze ein bisschen zum lenken
ich hab die ganze zeit hier noch nicht
doch irgendwie fossilien sind wie läuse
und letztlich besitz fehler eingeräumt
ja wahrscheinlich meine minister nicht
wieder weg wenn ich mich einfach aus
aber ich muss sie wirklich an zu sammeln
das nicht sein ich lasse jetzt einfach
mal direkt hier neben noch machen
glauben so die gemeinschaft versagen ist
ein idealist unsortierter gemacht diese
explosion habe ich glaub nicht dass man
vorher genau so schlimm wenn man packte
hier die ganze sache wieder fallen so
wundervoll lasse
schaut mal ganz kurz auf was man kino
ging es jetzt schon irgendwas geworden
ist nee das ist auch auf dem weg aber
ich habe jetzt jeden moment einen
entchen sword es ist sofort da ich habe
meine lieben freunde in 10 sekunden
ich habe ein engines hat +8 attack the
match damit ist man eben aus angreifen
ich möchte das mit rechtsklick mit
linksklick
oktober richtig blitze rausgehen geht
das relativ schnell kaputt jetzt brennt
fast nee ich habe gerade ein williger
getötet und jetzt habe ich mich also
billiger verwandeln ich war mit meiner
luft deswegen muss die schnelle etwas
suchen zum landen nicht hasse das selber
wurde das essen hier und diese fans
jetzt wo sich alle an pflanzen cathy
zimmermann stahl und hin und her ich bin
des vertriebs ist alles anders alles neu
ich glaube zwei diamant blöcke macht
dann so eine tolle statue formen haus
der hund aus dem man einfach weil ich ja
kein understatement will hier meine
position im projekt mein bisschen
klarstellen ja mantel luca schlägt
wieder zu kritik
wir brauchen was zu essen ja machen
stelle ich hier schon wieder am essen
man muss erst mal vorbeikommen mehr
essen geben ja ich auch nicht mehr so
viel ich muss mir auch bald mal wieder
strom menschen
strom ist ja du hinten gut ich will mal
zu euch mal vor ihr in welchem portal
ehrlich ich glaube schon
ich will jetzt einfach dass man die vier
minuten
wir haben jetzt noch eine minute ok
kräftigste chefs nicht mehr
aber irgendwann kommen besuchen ok in
meiner 1 stunden folge sind eine 1
stunden verfügt dann werde ich hier so
viel machen so weit ich wollte es mal
ganz kurz in hänner holen
mein hemmer des tores mit diesem hammer
wollte ich dann dahin eine skulptur aus
diamant machen mit meinem skin clarion
von crafter
das sieht hier noch kurz fertig und dann
werde ich mich die nächste folge auf
jeden fall dran machen dass ihr mir
alles mal mehr komplett durchzulesen
jetzt habe ich ein bisschen was gemacht
hier bis auf jeden wunsch und stahl
schon mal ganz gut
wollte ich ja wie funktioniert das ganze
nicht so wie ich mir das gewünscht habe
gefühl kenn dich gott oh gott wie geht
einfach gar nichts hier dass ich mit
tiger halte ich aber aus jeder mann
deine stadt
das ist ja bei müll haft das hat er gar
nicht funktioniert da egal wer kann
schon mal ein schmerzen aber ich warte
jetzt auch eben wir machen die folge die
folge es dann zu ende wenn weil wir sind
bei 1440 die folge stand sein wenn man
die noaa da ist weil das sollte so noch
eine halbe minute dauern und es passt
jetzt erst mal mental und so nur leider
gerade nicht ins haus bekommen reisende
nicht gut
ich sollte hier mal ganz kurz ein paar
sachen wir sortieren eigentlich ich
mache mich betitelt das immer als
sortieren aber letztendlich mache ich
eigentlich gar nichts eine dino kiste
machen und alles und alle die nur sachen
kläglich
diese brachiosaurus dna wird dann auch
noch mal jemand für mich ja alle die nur
ein
mein zweites so das werde ich dann in
der nächsten folge hier hinsetzen weil
die nur dann wird er hier aus schlüpfen
der fehler die raptor das wäre ich mit
dem singleplayer angucken wie das ganze
dann wieder aussieht und ob der böse
soll ob der cool aussieht und welche
mittel op die an wert und dann sollte
doch eigentlich nicht verschwinden und
ich verstehe jetzt neben geld nämlich
ganz kurz vor dem nicht muss man eine
million suns ansammelte
ich werde schon an verschiedenen ich
weiß nicht was ich jetzt machen soll ich
jetzt die anzahl in die williams ganz
kurz hans namens sind weg das habe ich
ihr die ganzen sachen von denen ja toll
jetzt müssen die ganzen sachen sortieren
wenn ich jetzt über ziehe ich wieder
möglich lockt jetzt aus ich bin schon
ganz auf dem screen das ok jetzt ganz
schnell
okay man die verabschiedung wenn es euch
gefallen hat gerne daumen da lassen auch
mal bei luca vorbeigucken und sonst